- Good morning.
Welcome to re:Invent day three.
Who's excited to be here?
(audience applauds)
Awesome.
So show of hands, who out in the crowd
is multi-cloud today in your business?
Who's multi-cloud? Okay,
so we have a lot of them.
So you're in luck.
So today you're gonna hear
about a real life multi-cloud
story with a real customer, a real CTO
telling you about their
process to go through it.
Good morning. My name is Rusty Grayson.
I'm an AWS Account Principal,
and I'll be one of the ones
presenting to you today.
Here's a quick look at our agenda.
After telling us about Crane Worldwide,
a billion dollar plus third
party logistics company.
Brandon Kuykendall, Chief
Technology Officer from Crane,
will give you a behind the
scenes look at the strategy
behind his organization's, move to AWS.
Akhil Melakunta, my colleague,
AWS Senior Solutions Architect,
will provide a deep dive
into how a joint team
thought or brought
Brandon's vision to reality.
We'll finish off the session
with some innovations
that Crane is bringing to
their business with agentic AI
and satellite communications.
So nobody likes cloud migration stories
that start off with
digital transformation.
So, we're not gonna do that today,
and nobody likes 17
bullet points on a slide
that nobody's gonna read anyway,
so we're not gonna do that either.
So let me tell you what happened.
Crane Worldwide, big logistics company,
moving stuff all over the world,
and they were spending money
on cloud infrastructure
that was not a valuable asset for them.
So they moved to AWS as
their primary cloud platform.
And when they did, they saved money,
they got faster and they
got more agile as well.
So you may be thinking,
Rusty, what is this another
cost cutting story where
they fired a bunch of people
and turned off the lights.
That's not what we're
gonna talk about today
because Crane got faster
and they got more scalable
and they're using satellites and AI.
So that's what you're about to hear.
And you're not gonna
hear about it from me.
You're gonna hear about it from Brandon,
the CTO, who actually did the work.
So here's the thing about
logistics, and I know this
because I asked them and they
told me, logistics is hard.
You've got ships, trucks,
planes, warehouses
all over the world, and
everybody wants to know
where their stuff is right
now, not in five minutes.
They want to know now.
And if Crane's technology can't tell them,
those customers are gonna go elsewhere.
So here's where it gets interesting
and we'll go over most of
this in the session today.
Crane made AWS their primary
cloud, and that's important.
Primary means most of their workloads,
most of their innovation
and most of their investment
in technology is now going to AWS.
But, and this is the real world talking,
they still operate in a
multi-cloud environment.
Some stuff runs on
Azure, some on OCI. Why?
Because that's how real enterprises work.
You've got acquisitions,
you've got vendor requirements,
you've got applications
that aren't worth moving,
at least not yet.
And you know what? That's okay.
The story today here is
not about cloud religion,
it's about making AWS the engine
that drives your business forward
while being smart about the rest.
So here's specifically
what Crane did with AWS.
First off cost optimization.
Real cost optimization,
where they reinvested savings
into modernization and
AI and into satellites.
Scale, Crane can now deploy
applications anywhere
in their network without
rebuilding everything.
And we'll show you what that
looks like on AWS today.
AI and a little hint, not the type of AI
that you ask to write a poem.
AI that optimizes supply chains
and predicts problems
before they even occur.
And finally, Amazon Leo,
Amazon's satellite network,
which means Crane can
now operate in places
where the internet
doesn't really exist today
in the middle of nowhere.
So what are you gonna learn
today in the next 50 minutes
in this session?
You're gonna learn four things.
Number one, how to migrate.
The real story, not the sanitized version.
How Crane and AWS moved as AWS
as their primary cloud platform
while keeping the other
clouds operational.
How they kept the business
running when they ripped out
the foundation and built it again.
Two, how to optimize.
What architectural decisions
did Brandon's team make?
What did they stop doing
that they thought they
needed to keep doing?
And here's the practical part,
how do you optimize in a
multi-cloud environment?
Three, modernize.
Containerization, serverless,
but more importantly,
how they got legacy applications
that people said were unmovable
and they moved them to AWS anyway,
where they could actually
do something with them.
And last, innovation,
the AI implementations.
We'll talk about that during this session.
The satellite part from Leo,
we'll talk about this in this session.
Most companies won't be
here for another two years.
Crane is there today,
and they're gonna tell you
what it's actually like.
So with that, I'd like to introduce you
to Brandon Kuykendall,
Crane Worldwide's Chief
Technology Officer.
Brandon. Thanks, Rusty.
(audience applauds)
- Okay, so let's start with who is Crane?
'Cause most of you guys
probably have never heard of us.
We're a 3PO, about a $3 billion
company that moves goods
around the world.
We're headquartered in Houston, Texas.
We were founded in 2008,
so a fairly young company.
We have over 150 offices
in 30 plus countries
around the world, about 4,000 employees.
We're privately held.
So we're very entrepreneurial as a company
we move fast, very, very fast.
And we use that as a
competitive advantage.
How does that play into why AWS
and why did we embark on this journey?
It was never about cost,
although we definitely
wanna be cost conscious.
It was about fueling
the pace of innovation.
We have to be able to move faster
and faster with more certainty
and are very, very secure, reliable,
and scalable infrastructure.
So that's what our aim and our goal was.
So why AWS?
Because their DNA is a lot like ours.
They're very, very entrepreneurial.
They like to move fast as well.
And they bring resources
and partner with you,
at least for us in a
way that we had not seen
with other providers.
So for Crane, we're customer
obsessed. A lot like AWS.
Our core values are integrity,
innovation, execution,
partnership, and ultimately results.
That's how we measure
everything is end results.
Okay, so I'll tell you guys a little bit
about the logistics landscape.
Most of you guys probably
aren't super familiar with it.
I have to thank our friends at Amazon
for really changing the game
and making my job a lot more difficult
because we constantly get the question of,
well, Amazon can tell me when
a package is on my porch.
Why can't you tell me, right?
So thanks a lot for changing the game.
Well, ours is a little
bit more complicated.
So we deal with multiple
modes of transport, right?
We're talking about air,
ocean, ground transportation.
We have warehouses all over the world.
We have to deal with the
complexities of tariff changes,
customs compliance, customs declarations,
all the way down to sometimes
partnering with our clients
to help them understand what materials
are actually in the
goods that they're moving
so that we can properly clear customs.
So as you can see, there's
a lot of documentation.
There's documents,
documents, more documents.
So our take on AI, at least for now,
is that it's best when
there's a human in the loop.
So a lot of what you'll hear
from us is deploying LLMs
to keep our logistics
professionals a loop,
make them more agile, ultimately faster,
and provide better
service for our clients.
We also have to track in real
time GPS throughout the world.
So a lot of data, a lot of data, right?
And we have to have an
infrastructure that can handle that,
especially in peak load times, right?
If you looked at our business,
there is a peak and our volumes
can sometimes go up 10x.
So we have to be able
to handle it every day
and scale to manage peak load.
Customs and tariffs, thank
you Trump administration
for making this much, much more difficult
for everybody around the globe.
But it did create an
opportunity for a lot of people
to really stand out and shine.
So what we have to do there is navigate
a growing complex network of tariffs,
customs regulations,
and filing appropriately
to keep goods moving.
Cost optimization.
When I say that, don't think
cloud cost optimization,
optimizing costs for our clients,
how we actually move their
goods throughout the world
and how we can save them
money most of all time
and predict and hit our service SLAs.
Which brings us to the
forecasting bit, right?
So Rusty's, right.
People don't want to just
know where are my things now?
They want to know, well, what
is gonna impact how my goods
move three months from
now, six months from now,
what are rates gonna be?
Is there gonna be political instability
that we should be on the lookout for?
Are there port strikes
that could impact the goods
that we need to move?
So a lot of complexity.
So our migration strategy,
what were we really trying to hit?
Provide rapid value to our clients.
We need to be able to move fast.
In order to be able to move fast,
we need to have an environment
that we can rely on,
from a deployment standpoint,
eliminate click ops
and human intervention, and
make things as repeatable
and consistent as possible.
That should help
accelerate our AI outcomes.
Because without being able
to move quickly, experiment
and ingest volumes of data,
you really limit yourself
from what you can do from
an agentic standpoint.
And then be ready for
growth in the future.
Obviously all of this has to
be in a secure, resilient,
and reliable environment.
So success factors for me, we
had to make absolutely certain
that we could deploy via code.
We took an engineering
first approach to everything
that we did during this migration.
To create reliability,
we had to be able to be
in multiple regions for
scalability and redundancy,
for business continuity.
And then where we could,
how do we modernize,
not just lift and shift, right?
Where could we actually take a look
and see where we could
use serverless options,
where we could reduce
some of the complexity
and simplify our environment.
The execution team.
So we had a lot of
expertise in other clouds,
but not a lot with AWS,
not to the same level
that we did with other providers.
So when we started,
I made it very clear
to our partners at AWS
that we were gonna need not only training,
which they put together
a tailored training plan
just for our staff, but
then we also wanted to take
the approach of professional
services would lead,
help our team get up to speed,
and then during the
transition we would flip
and we would lead and they would assist,
which is exactly what we did.
And then long term living
with managed services
to help us be able to cost arbitrage
some of the mundane patching and the like.
And then partnering with
them to create a patchwork
of support around the globe 24/7 365,
which is what we have in place today.
And then we wanted to push limits, right?
Anybody who works in our organization
knows we like to go fast,
we like to innovate,
we like to experiment.
And then ultimately we
want to take what wins
and get it to production
as quickly as possible.
And we do that in hopes
of creating an uncommon
client experience,
especially for clients
of logistics providers
who historically have
not innovated as quickly
as other verticals.
And some of that includes
real time visibility,
predictive optimization,
human in the loop workflows.
Again, I'm gonna keep
hearkening back to that
because for us, you saw the complexity,
there's just a lot that is
between the ears of people
who are specialists around the globe,
who know local regulations,
who know the carrier bases
that needs to be leveraged.
And so we attempt to
keep humans in the loop
at every step in the process.
And then we absolutely had
to have global scalability.
Like I said, we operate
in multiple countries
around the globe, over 150 offices.
So it was really, really important for us
to be able to scale out globally.
Okay, execution strategy,
I'm just gonna pull these up
so that you guys can see
those as we go through.
But automation, we took an
engineering first approach.
This was not lift and shift.
We wanted to eliminate all of our ClickOps
all of them, right?
And really the reason why is
so that we can have certainty
as we move fast, as we deploy,
we have a way to orchestrate deployment
and then we have a way to
quickly recover in the event
that we made a mistake, which
is inevitable it happens.
Reliability, uptime, uptime, uptime.
We're now judged just like
a lot of other solution
providers, SaaS companies.
We have uptime SLAs with our clients
for things like our APIs, our reporting.
So we had to make certain
that we could meet
those uptime requirements.
And then scalability, we
talked a little bit about load.
I'll just give you a for
instance that might resonate
when we're ramping up to
Christmas season, right?
There's a lot of goods that
come into the United States.
And so in August you'll
see a huge peak, right?
We have to be able to manage that peak
and it's different for
the different cycles
for different industries.
Business continuity
absolutely had to make certain
that we could hit our RPOs and RTOs
and that we tested those and
prove that we could hit them,
not just on paper.
And then modernization
obviously, where we could,
we wanna make things more simpler
and we wanna make things more resilient
using serverless compute.
And then latency. Latency
is a big one for us.
Akhil will go into some of
the latency requirements.
Just like a lot of you guys I'm sure
we have vendor applications,
some can handle latency better than others
and some have very strict
latency requirements
that we had to adhere to.
So with that, I'm gonna
turn it over to Akhil.
- Thank you Brandon for that
overview of how you came up
with the strategy for our team.
So the way we got started with Crane,
is we took what was Brandon's
vision and Crane's vision
of the migration strategy.
We started working backwards with them.
The reason them being on stage today
is some of the simplification
and efficiencies
that Crane achieved that you can take back
to your own environments
and apply them as well.
So we thought it is
valuable for you for us
to share this information today.
So let's dive in.
So working backwards
from Crane objectives,
we brought with four principles
that were very key in the way
that we have designed the migration.
We started off by deciding
that Crane would require
a foundational environment
with landing zone.
But lot of customers,
when we work with proposing landing zone,
the usual pushback we get
is there is an impression
that it is always a trade
off between security
and agility for teams.
Am I gonna create a more
secure foundational environment
where now my developers are restricted
that they cannot move fast enough.
That is not the case,
you'll see that in the way
how Crane was able to adopt landing zone,
but still was able to be
flexible enough to use
some of the partner solutions
that they were working with.
They wanted to operate in
three different clouds,
but still wanted a simple design.
So that's one of the major objectives
that we went back when we actually
designed their architecture.
They wanted to move into
AWS but wanted to move along
with AWS while their
team is getting trained.
So how did we pace that?
How did we train their team
and how they're leading of
some of those initiatives
are interesting for you to learn as well.
And modernization, like Brandon mentioned,
how do we not just migrate and leave?
How do we keep continuously modernizing
so they're future ready for scalability
and what's coming in their business?
So the overall migration
approach started off
by the AWS Professional
services team partnering up
with AWS solution architects
and some of the specialist
essays that we have.
We went in and we tried to discover
what is the lay of the land for Crane?
What is the landscape? What
is the consumption today?
Which translated into a cost analysis
of what are the spending right now?
Because when we are moving
from cloud to cloud,
usually the cost is not
a huge factor in savings,
but you're not comparing apples to apples.
So we would often go back
to this cost analysis
throughout the migration saying,
are we proposing the
right solution for them?
Are we making things better?
Are we moving them to a
more expensive solution,
whether it is compute
database or other things?
During the same period,
we have also handled
executive visioning sessions
with Crane team, you know, so
that the executive alignment
is in place.
And we also had trained technical
teams from Crane as well.
So they're along in the
journey of this migration.
So we went on to actually
mobilize some of the workloads,
which is where we started to plan.
So the planning phase started off
by actually designing their
landing zone environment,
creating an operating model,
understanding how Crane
operates in cloud today,
and sort of also visioning
how they would operate
for post migration as well.
So then the actual migration kicked off.
If you see the parallel lines up there,
those parallel lines mean
those are different waves.
We didn't just take a big bang approach
of moving everything all at a time.
We started picking each application,
building portfolio for that application.
What are the dependencies
involved, complexities involved
before we started moving applications.
So that helped us take the
learnings from each application
and take those learnings and
efficiencies into the next one.
So we are doing it more and
more efficiently as we progress.
And post migration we also optimized
some of those applications
and we continue to modernize them today.
So this is their landing
zone environment, right?
So they have a typical
architecture of control,
plane of management
accounts sitting on the top,
orchestrating multi account design,
enabling, creating accounts.
They have aggregated backups,
audit, logging, et cetera.
But what the flexibility part comes here.
Crane wanted a centralized
firewall control plane
where they control firewall
for all the traffic.
We were able to achieve that
and put that into the design.
And the whole infrastructure
as code foundation
for post migration was based off
of how well we implement landing zone.
So this was very critical
for us to implement.
So yeah, in the same process,
we had used automation
for any security configuration
remediations as well.
So any changes to configuration,
security aspects were all
remediated with automation.
At the end of the implementation,
what we were able to
achieve is a one stop shop
for Crane teams to deploy accounts
with a baseline accounts created.
A dev team or a data engineering team
wants to create an account.
They have a base account
structured with all the security
and governing policies
that are applied to it.
So that security posture stays standard
over a period of time.
So let me walk you through
some of the simplicities
that we achieved.
Usually customers, when
they try to implement
cloud migrations in AWS,
they at least operate in two regions.
So the way we set up
connectivity between regions
and VPCs is you connect
every VPC in each region
to a transit gateway.
Shat the VPCs can talk to each other.
Now you're trying to connect
two regions together.
And then we would set up
a transit gateway peering.
And then now the customers
have an on-premise environment
or another cloud environment.
We use direct connect for
this peering connections
to connect with so they can
connect to those things.
Then we learned Crane operates
in six different regions.
Now we were talking about
transit gateway connections
in each region, peering
connections between them.
The fun thing is transit gateway.
The routing between those
transit gateways look like this.
If we had implemented this.
This moved away from the
principle and our directive
that we got from Brandon's team
is we wanted a simple environment.
This doesn't look simple to me.
So that's we took a step back,
we went to a drawing board,
like how do we implement a
multi-cloud architecture design
that is still simple enough
that they can actually operate at scale?
That's when we started looking...
AWS had come up, you
know, around the same time
with a service called Cloud WAN.
This is a global managed WAN
network service that we have.
Where you can connect networks
from different regions
seamlessly without having
to manage the routing
between them.
When you create Cloud WAN,
we create what's called
a core cloud WAN network
that spans across all the
regions that you operate in.
And we manage the
connectivity between the VPCs
that you put in that core network.
Cloud WAN creates what's
called a core edge network,
CEN is what we call it.
We put it in each region
of where you operate.
So every VPC that connects into that CNE
can connect to any other VPC
that you put in that segment.
Now another thing that we
learned when we started off
the migration was Crane didn't have
a proper network segmentation
in their Azure network.
So that's where the feature of cloud one
to use network segments came into picture.
Let's say you have six
production VPCs in six, you know,
three different regions.
You can have one network segment,
you can call it a core network segment.
You can connect all those
VPCs into that segment.
And now you have achieved
not just connectivity
between those VPCs, you also achieved
the network segmentation
that you would require.
Now let me show you how we
actually implemented this
for Crane.
When we started connecting
two regions together,
we would create a production segment.
So every production VPC
that is in those two
regions now is connected
through production segment.
Now to the connectivity through
Microsoft and on premise,
we would create a direct connect
segment within Cloud WAN,
where the production
segment can now connect
to this direct connect using
direct connect segment.
Now, with that connectivity established,
we can connect with Cloud
WAN multiple regions
into Azure environment to any subscription
in a more simplified fashion.
Now, Crane operates in six regions.
They added a new region or a new VPC,
they just have to add those
VPCs into the segment,
and their connectivity is established
without having to manage or
update any routing tables
for transit gateways
or peering connections.
So post that implementation, we found out,
like Brandon mentioned,
they had a lot of vendor
specific applications
that required very low latency connection.
So we realized they were
connecting to Oracle Cloud,
which was located in Phoenix, Arizona,
and we didn't have an
availability zone located there.
How do we achieve a low latency connection
if we don't have an availability
zone in that region?
That's where we started
looking into local zones.
So Phoenix had a local zone.
So local zone is an area
of presence that we have
where we put compute,
storage and databases
in most highly populated
cities across the globe.
So we picked a local
zone that is much closer
to where the Oracle is sitting,
and we had directly, we were
able to establish connectivity
through Direct Connect into Oracle Cloud
with fewer network hops.
At post implementation,
we were able to achieve latencies
as low as two milliseconds
from AWS into Oracle Cloud.
So the big biggest
takeaway for customers here
is you can think about multi-cloud.
The biggest pushback
we get from executives
when we talk about multi-cloud is,
is it gonna get too
complex for me to manage?
For the sake of being, you know,
for the sake of being more flexible
or having more choices between cloud?
Am I compromising performance?
It's not really the case.
You can still operate
between multiple clouds,
have a simplified networking
and design architecture,
have a foundational environment
where you push automation
in the way that you operate
and still be performing
for your business.
Now let me show you how
Crane's posture looks today
post migration, when we
move the applications.
So every application that we move
with that foundational
environment now operates
has regional resiliency
that every workload now
is can fail over between
availability zones
in that same region.
And they also have the ability to spin up
or bring the same application
backup in another region
if at all a region has to go down.
We use services like Elastic
Disaster Inquiry to replicate.
Most of all the critical applications,
and we use Terraform for any application
to be spin up for infrastructure
or core deployments.
So post migration, Brandon
spoke about time to market.
How do we make Crane's team more efficient
so that the time to market has improved?
It comes from two factors, right?
How fast can they deliver new
features to their business?
That comes from how well
they're governed between teams.
How fast can they take a business outcome
from their business,
deploy the infrastructure
that is required, develop the code,
and how do they push it fast enough?
I think automating all of
their both infrastructure
and code deployment
process into one repository
now enables them to act fast
and serve their customers much faster.
So, so far we have discussed the way
that they have migrated, you
know, now they're in AWS.
How did they approach migration?
Most customers who are new to AWS,
Crane was a customer who was new to AWS.
When we work with them, we
usually do a lift and shift.
Let's take everything that
you have, let's put it in AWS
and let's think about modernization.
Brandon's directive to us
was, we need you to rethink
everything that you move over,
we need you to re-platform,
we need IAC, we need automation.
We don't want you to move
us from a VM to another VM
without adding value to us.
They wanted value from day one.
So that's where we took every application
that was forced from vendors,
you know, vendor specific applications.
We re-platform with automation,
moved them onto AWS.
Now the kicker is when Bannon mentioned
about how we wanted to
flip the team around
where his team takes more lead
and AWS takes backseat at a point.
That's where the refactoring, you know,
the time where we started refactoring,
that's where we have seen the shift.
Crane team came back to us and said,
we don't want you guys
doing all the work anymore.
We got trained, you know, we got,
you know, we have teams
now that are unscaled
they understand the environment
better for any applications
that Crane has built natively
within their business
that they want to move to more modern
cloud native applications
on AWS they wanted to do it
themself and they just
wanted AWS to be there
to just guiding them.
So think about a native
application built on Azure.
Even if they were using managed services,
like managed services for databases,
they would still want to move
into a managed service on AWS,
but wanted to use services
like serverless and B,
move off of SQL and even
move towards Postgresql
and have options like
global scaling enabled now.
So Crane team, as we have seen
have shifted from where we were leading
some of the migration initiatives.
Now they're designing how they
want to move those workloads
and also we're picking taking our advisory
during the process and have
really transformed the way
they're operating in cloud now.
At the end of it, what you
see now is Crane operating
more than 2,500 distinct AWS resources
with over 34,000 of Terraform
code return for them
with over 150 modules within Terraform
built to manage their environment.
A foundational shift in the way
they were operating in Azure
towards an AWS where they have
taken their automation focus
as they move any workloads after.
Now they didn't stop there.
They started looking more
things that they can innovate
that can power from this migration.
I think Rusty now will walk us through
what are most of some of
the forward looking outcomes
they're working with us. Rusty?
- Thanks Akhil.
Okay, so vision ahead.
So Brandon and Akhil
have talked to you about
a lot of the architecture
and what Brandon,
you know, what he wanted to do
and how we brought that to AWS.
So you know a lot about that so far,
but lemme just say this, I've known Crane
for about a year and a half or so,
and I can tell you one thing
they do not stand still.
So these couple of things
that we'll talk about,
and we've only got time
to highlight a couple,
but let's go over what
they're gonna build next.
So Brandon mentioned some
of this in his opening,
but the third party logistics industry
is just full of challenges.
You know, the complexities.
So all of these complexities
we looked at and we said,
hey, how can we go tackle
some of these complexities,
solve some of these
really important problems?
So I'm gonna summarize
just a few of them here
about what we went as our
direction to start solving.
So the first thing is
communications velocity.
So Crane is just constantly
talking with customers,
brokers, warehouses, operators
and drivers and all that,
you know, constant communication
creates dozens of messages
for each product that gets shipped.
Second, there's challenges
with predicting deliveries.
Yes, Crane can tell you
where your shipment is today,
but customers want to know
when is it gonna arrive
and can I start looking
out into the future?
Like Brandon talked about.
So third, and this one's really important,
Crane operates warehouses globally.
And if you think about
what they have to do,
they've got to staff
warehouses efficiently.
If they don't have enough,
then you're gonna start creating
bottlenecks for shipments
that are coming through their pipeline.
But if they staff them too much,
then you're burning people and burning
the staff unfortunately, and
you're just wasting money.
So we wanted to make sure we
talked about warehouses too.
And then finally, just again,
the last one I wanted to highlight
is just manual processes.
So Crane teams are, you know,
just constantly manually
verifying documents,
cross-referencing data between systems,
making phone calls to
confirm and what is that?
That's really just a
not a lot of value add
in those particular activities,
but they're really necessary friction
that slows everything down
and introduces human error.
So Brandon and his team realized
that they wanted to take a crack at this.
So that's where we came
in with agentic AI.
So I'm gonna just very
briefly talk to you about
a few of the AI agents that
we are starting to build
with Crane.
So number one, the booking agent.
So the booking agent handles
the entire ordering process,
capturing requirements, checking capacity,
and confirming the order in seconds.
Second, the locator agent,
so the locator agent proactively
monitors every shipment
in real time answering the
"Where's my shipment question?"
in seconds.
The exceptions agent.
So the exceptions agent
instantly identifies issues
and either resolves them autonomously
or sends with context information
for a human to make a decision on.
So this is one that Brandon's
real passionate about
and exceptions handling is a really big
industry-wide issue that
we're hoping to solve
with agentic AI.
So next is predictor agent.
So predictor agents will
analyze historical data,
current conditions to forecast delay
in a particular shipment.
And then next the negotiator agent.
So this handles carrier negotiation
by analyzing market conditions,
historical performance
and capacity to secure
optimal pricing 24/7.
So really important to understand
this is just, you know,
five of the particular agents
that we've got identified now,
but with Amazon Bedrock
and Bedrock AgentCore,
we can see Crane adopting AI agents across
every part of their business.
So there's not enough in
this particular session
to do a dive deep into their AI strategy.
But I wanna share with you
the three particular areas
that we focused on.
Number one, we're we're
focused on establishing secure
government access to foundation models
through Amazon Bedrock.
So this is absolutely critical
because Crane operates in
a highly regulated industry
with sensitive documents
and we couldn't have a
Wild West approach to AI.
Also, Amazon Bedrock provides
Crane with API access
to foundation models without
managing any infrastructure.
More importantly, it gives them
enterprise grade governance.
Second, we are building and
deploying AI agents securely
and at scale with a
quick path to production.
This is where Bedrock AgentCore
has been really transformative for us.
We can take a new use
case, prototype an agent,
test it with real data and
deploy it to production quickly.
And that's been game
changers for us and Crane.
And last, and this one's really important
was really just transformational for us
as we started talking about AI.
Is we have to use the data
that's there from Crane today.
So Crane has decades
of operational systems,
things like transportation
management systems or TMSs,
warehouse management systems or WMSs.
I've learned that, I think
y'all are teaching me
those terms, customs platforms,
carrier APIs and customer portals.
So short stories, we
couldn't rip and replace
all that stuff.
These are their systems
of records and they work
and we wouldn't wanna rip
and replace them anyway.
But the key part is
our AI agentic solution
had to work with their existing
platform so that was a must.
So this is the agentic AI
sort of call our architecture
that we're planning
moving forward.
So starting over at the left
is the front end applications layer.
This is where users will
actually interact with AI agents.
In the center there in the box
is Amazon Bedrock AgentCore.
So this is where the intelligence will be,
where the AI agents actually operate.
Moving over to the right
between the AgentCore
and the data layer.
It's where we're building a
critical integration tier.
The AgentCore gateway, MCP
servers and custom tools.
And then if I could direct
your attention all the way over
to the right is that data layer
that we talked about just a minute ago.
So that's existing data
systems integration.
So systems that have been running
Cranes business for years.
So things like TMS/WMS, financial systems.
So these are the systems of record
and they'll continue to
operate just as they do.
So if there's one thing I could
encourage you to take away,
so our architectural
principles here are...
We're not replacing these systems at all,
we're augmenting them with intelligence.
The data will flow up through
the integration layer,
get processed by our agents
and insights will flow back.
So, what you're looking at here
is our agentic AI roadmap for Crane.
So the last innovation that
I wanted to bring up here
before we close out is...
Has anybody seen anything
on Amazon Leo this week?
So this is really exciting for us at AWS
and it goes beyond software and AI.
So one of the fundamental challenges
in global logistics is connectivity.
Crane operates warehouses,
distribution centers
all over the world in a
lot of remote locations.
So traditional internet connectivity
sometimes just isn't available.
Sometimes it's really expensive
or sometimes it's just not really good.
So that's why we're planning
to leverage Amazon LEO
AWS's satellite constellation.
It's gonna fundamentally change
how we think about connectivity for Crane.
So there's really four areas
that Crane is going to focus on
with Amazon Leo.
So first and foremost,
business continuity.
It's kind of an important
thing for a company like Crane.
So reliable internet that allows them
to establish robust backup
and recovery systems.
So that's kind of first and
foremost with Amazon Leo.
Second, weather resistant connectivity
during storms and severe weather events.
And for a logistics company like Crane,
that's really, really critical.
And then last Amazon Leo
provides comprehensive network redundancy.
So with enterprise
architecture best practices
and Crane does this,
they build in redundancy
all along the way.
So redundant servers, multiple
availability zones in AWS,
diverse network paths.
So Amazon LEO will now be part
of their redundancy strategy.
So it's not just another
connectivity option for Crane,
it's really a strategic enable for them.
So it ensures business continuity,
direct cloud connectivity as well.
So talk a little bit about
direct to cloud connectivity
with Amazon Leo.
This is really an
architecturally significant thing
for customers including Crane.
So when remote sites connect
to AWS, traffic typically flows
to the public internet, multiple
ISBs, internet exchanges
and network hops.
So what does that do?
It's gonna create latency.
Latency, potential
security vulnerabilities.
So Amazon LEO will change this.
Lower latency means that applications
that are in remote areas
will perform just as fast
as those that are in their
Houston headquarters.
So it's gonna be a real
game changer for them.
So remote sites will become extensions
of AWS cloud infrastructure.
So again, if we're implementing
or as we implement AI,
then those AI agents
can perform just as well
at a remote location as they
do in a major metro area.
So the last last thing is, you know,
Leo really is gonna provide
cloud grade connectivity
to places where it's never existed before.
So we're excited about
their plans with Amazon Leo.
So here I'm gonna pass it back to Brandon
and he's gonna give us a
summary of all the innovations
and the measurements
that his team undertook
on this move to AWS, so Brandon?
- Thanks Rusty.
So we have a rule in our organization,
if you can't measure
it, you can't manage it
and it probably didn't happen.
So we like stats, we like data.
So I'll just throw a few
things up for you here.
We talked about moving fast, right?
So we estimate that we've
increased our capability
to deploy by about 70%.
Largely because we've
taken a lot of click ops
out of deployment pipelines, right?
So we kind of estimate
over 10,000 operations
have been automated.
So now we're in a position
where we feel confident
with deployments, at least more confident
than we did before.
This was never about cost,
although I said we wanna be
good stewards of our resources.
So we ended up being about net neutral
even with the multi-cloud implementation,
which is a testament to the AWS team
and the design that they
helped us come up with.
And from a performance
standpoint, we talked about this,
but we measure our latency.
So sub two millisecond latency
for across cloud solutions is pretty good.
So we feel pretty confident about that.
And then from a security
standpoint, you know,
we measure drift now between
what we actually have deployed
and what our Terraform models
say should be deployed.
And so we can manage drift,
which helps us feel a lot more resilient
in our ability to be able
to push changes quickly
and know that from a security standpoint
no one's opened a door or a window
that we don't know about
and don't have sight on.
So with that, I will turn
it back over to you...
- Okay, so we just wanted
to finish the session off
with a few questions.
So Brandon, I've got one for you.
So undertaking a multi-cloud migration,
kind of, maybe it didn't
keep you up at night,
but maybe talk us through, you know,
sort of your mindset in going
into a multi-cloud migration
with AWS.
- Well it did keep me
up at night at first,
but you know, it was really about getting
to know the AWS organization.
Having confidence in our
ability to upskill our staff
and you guys helping us
create a training plan
and not only for, you know,
our staff to be able to learn
new skills, but then also
to help them be hands on
as we transition from
AWS leading the effort
to our teams leading the effort.
And we feel very, very
confident in our posture now.
So I think that was
probably more than anything,
look, the technical
things we could work out.
The cost we could work out,
but really having a firm foundation
that we felt really
confident moving forward
that we could administer largely ourselves
was really, really important.
- Yeah, awesome. Thank you for that.
And I do see some of the Crane folks,
folks on Brandon's team
out in the audience.
And I do have to say we couldn't
have done it without you,
so thanks for all your help.
Akhil, how about you? Any
questions for Brandon?
- Yeah, so Brandon, you work
with multiple cloud providers.
Probably wide variety of tech teams.
What stood out with the AWS
tech team that you worked with?
- I think it's the partnership.
Like I said, the DNA between our teams
is very, very similar.
You guys are very entrepreneurial.
You come up with ideas
like you talked about
with the VPC connections
for our backup to OCI
and the latency that we needed to hit.
So thinking outside the
box, staying on task,
and measuring everything,
moving very, very quickly
and then keeping the goal in mind.
It wasn't just a lift
and shift conversion.
We wanted to take this opportunity
to create an environment
that was more resilient, more scalable,
that we felt confident moving forward in.
And you guys, I mean
the partnership there,
I couldn't have asked for anything better.
- Awesome. Thank you Brandon.
Okay, so that ends our session.
We will be around here if
you have any questions,
but have a good rest of
re:Invent, thank you.